cult leader religious found a sci-fi
innovative military hero there's a lot
of question marks when it comes to l ron
Hubbard's life the life story he is told
over the years and the life story that
many of his followers point to is not
the same story that documents and other
official sources tell though details of
his life are uncertain there is no
question that his life was a fascinating
trip from a Midwestern childhood to an
internationally recognized writer and
influence at the Nan who rose to
influence some of Hollywood's biggest
names was born far from the land of
celebrity Hubbard was born in 1911 in
Tilden Nebraska his mother was a teacher
at his father was a military man when
Hubbard was only 2 his family moved from
Nebraska to Montana and Hubbard grew up
in a town house though he has made
claims that the family lived on a ranch
that's just one of many claims that has
been debunked by family members
government officials and others who
actually knew Hubbard as he was growing
up and starting his career
Hubbard's father was in the Navy and
travel around the world but Hubbard
didn't accompany him outside of the
country some stories about Hubbard's
teen life do suggest that he lived in
places like China Guam and Japan but
it's not clear if this is in fact part
of his official life or part of the
mystique built up around him and a study
of Eastern medicine as part of his
Scientology persona truly separating
fact from fiction is difficult when it
comes to Hubbard's life the Hubbard
family briefly lived in Washington State
and Hubbard attended school for some
years on the west coast then returned to
Montana to finish high school and live
with his grandparents while his parents
lived overseas after graduating from
high school Hubbard left the Midwest and
headed east to the nation's capital at
George Washington University he studied
engineering but dropped out after only
two years due to failing grades without
a college degree and no prospects ahead
of him Hubbard turned to his imagination
and began penning sci-fi and horror
stories to earn a living he was only
making a penny a word though and he had
to write prolifically
in order to earn enough to live on you
don't get rich writing science fiction
if you want to get rich you start a
religion
Hubbard once said this man's well he
certainly knew what he was talking about
because he had to crank out so many
stories Hubbard now holds the Guinness
world record for the most translated and
published author in the world during the
1930s he wrote under several pseudonyms
and wrote dozens of stories across
nearly every literary genre he published
novels and some reports even say that he
wrote as many as 100,000 words a month
science fiction became what he was best
known for and he even moved in the
social circles of men like Isaac Asimov
and Robert Heinlein Hubbard's writing it
also caught the attention of Hollywood
he wrote the script for the secret of
Treasure Island and claims that he
helped write several other movies
including John Ford stagecoach but his
name doesn't actually appear in the
credits for this movie in the year 2000
his work was prominently featured on the
big screen when his novel Battlefield
Earth was made into a movie starring
none other than devout Scientologist
John Travolta Hubbard's writing career
like so many other American men's
careers was interrupted by the outbreak
of World War two he joined the Navy
Reserve in 1941 and upon the
recommendation of his congressman he was
made a lieutenant the stories of
Hubbard's military career have been
polished and exaggerated for the benefit
of Scientology tales have overseas
heroism abounds hence the scientology
version of his war record has him
receiving 21 medals for his actions
during the war including injuries that
supposedly left him blinded and crippled
in reality though the story of Hubbard's
military service is a little bit
different official military records
showed that he never actually left the
continental United States during the war
and he also wasn't a hero
far from it in fact he lost the command
of his ship after a number of mishaps
including having his crew fire upon what
he thought was a submarine off the coast
of Oregon well this submarine actually
just turned out to be a large floating
long even though Hubbard was relieved of
his command he was allowed to stay in
the Navy on in active duty it was in
1950 that he officially resigned his
commission and left the military behind
for good
when are birds active students in the
Navy were over he stayed on the west
coast moving to Los Angeles in 1945
hitman married in 1933 but his wife
wouldn't bring along the whole family to
California from Washington to live there
later Byrd said his wife left him
because he was a cripple I was abandoned
by family and friends as a supposedly
hopeless cripple and a probable burden
upon them for the rest of my days is how
his version of the story supposedly goes
in California without his wife or
children Hubbard found himself with a
new family of sorts and Aleister Crowley
that famous practitioner of magic was
leading a group that would say a cult
called Otto Templi Orientis
Hubbard joined the group and found an
outlet for his interest in science
fiction thea cults and the fantastical
hubbard moved in with Jack Parsons and
his girlfriend Sarah Parsons also
members of the group and the three they
became close friends perhaps too close
because eventually Hubbard began
sleeping with Parsons girlfriends and
Parsons didn't seem to mind soon another
female Marjorie Cameron joined their
group and Parsons started sleeping with
her but their sexual encounters had an
occult end goal they wanted to
impregnate Cameron with the spawn of
Satan apparently this required Hubbard
to watch the couple while they engaged
in intercourse their behavior Munn
surprisingly never resulted in the spawn
of Satan but these exploits did end in a
lasting relationship between Hubbard and
Northrup the couple were married in 1946
but Hubbard hadn't yet divorced his
first wife it took a year for his first
wife to find out that he had married
again making Hubbard a bigamist for an
entire year the divorce filings do not
paint a pretty picture of Hubbard's
first marriage among the accusations
included in the papers is that
systematic torture beatings
strangulations and scientific torture
experiments were among the things
Hubbard's first wife was subjected to
once divorced and once again monogamous
Hubbard and Northrup moved to Laguna
Beach then to Georgia and they finally
settled in New Jersey it was there that
he began crafting the work that served
as the basis for Scientology
on May the 5th 1950 that work that was
introduced to the world the publication
of Dianetics the modern science of
mental health brought Hubbard's ideas
about psychology to the masses within
months the book was selling at her rate
of thousands a week and was translated
into several languages essentially
Dianetics thought that memories which
Hubbard referred to as engrams are the
reason that people experience the
psychological pain and its associated
health problems in the book he described
how people can and release their engrams
and work towards becoming clear this is
the term he used for being cured of all
the ills caused by engrams he even
alleged that he cured his own war
injuries through the use of Dianetics
and he even said that leukemia was
caused by an Engram and could be cured
through Dianetics leukemia is evidently
psychosomatic in origin and at least
eight cases of leukemia had been treated
successfully by Dianetics after medicine
had traditionally given up the source of
leukemia has been reported to be an
Engram containing the phrase it turns my
blood to water
Hubbard's well he was one who never
understate his achievements and he had
no doubts about what Dianetics could
mean for the world and for human health
a milestone for man comparable to his
discovery of fire and superior to his
invention of the wheel and the arch well
Hubbard was sure about his theory of
psychology the scientific world wasn't
so quick to agree as the book continued
to sell and Dianetics groups began to
pop up around the nation scientists and
medical professionals began to speak
about their disbelief in Dianetics the
American Psychological Association
dismissed Dianetics as did Scientific
American
they said that Hubbard's ideas weren't
based in fact and he had nothing but
baseless promises nonetheless the
teachings of Dianetics they kept
spreading Hubbard spends much of 1950
touring the country giving lectures on
Dianetics and conducting seminars
Dianetics groups sprouted up in large
cities and people started sending money
to the groups wanting to start on the
path to becoming clear or wanting to
learn how they could help others become
clear by being what is called a
Dianetics auditor I mean
all the traveling and amid all the fame
Hubbard couldn't keep his second
marriage going nor could he keepers
finances in line he was having an affair
with his public relations assistant and
Dianetics foundations around the country
were floundering only a couple of years
after his book was an astounding success
l ron Hubbard was divorced a second time
and it wasn't looking like Dianetics was
going to be any sort of long-term
lasting movement but Hubbard well he had
a standing charisma and he had a theory
that people that easily latched onto and
wanted to believe in one of the
Dianetics believers was a millionaire
named Don Purcell he hadn't lost faith
in Hubbard's and Dianetics yet and he
wanted to support the cause so he poured
money into a building and a brand new
foundation for Dianetics research in
Kansas but his support and his ideas
they were no match for Hubbard after he
and Hubbard had disagreements about the
foundation that organization fell apart
and ultimately ended up losing its money
when it had to cover the depths of other
lapsed Dianetics foundations though the
foundation in Kansas didn't work out it
wasn't a total loss for Hubbard he was
able to launch Hubbard College in the
States and even met his next bride there
she was only 18 and the two moved
together to Phoenix Arizona during this
period Hubbard took the next leap
forward in sharing his ideas about
psychology and the human experience he
started working on putting his ideas
about Dianetics into a larger spiritual
and philosophical frame in other words
it was creating Scientology in 1954 the
Church of Scientology officially
launched however as with much of
Scientology's history there is dispute
about which church was the official
start was it the one in California
founded by a member or was it Hubbard's
organization in New Jersey
either way Hubbard to put forth the
ideas for the structure of the church
and it's his name that will forever be
linked with Scientology all right so
well what is Scientology
well Hubbard described it this way
Scientology is the study of knowingness
it increases one's knowingness but if a
man were totally aware of what was going
on around him he would find it
relatively simple to handle any outlet
in that and according to the church's
website Scientology teachings contain
answers for nearly everything a human
could want to know contains they're in
our arms
to life's most profound mysteries the
enigma of existence the riddle of death
the realization of states not even
described in earlier literature also
from these works come Scientology
technologies to rear children repair
families educate organize and provide
relief in times of illness or suffering
by 1956 the Church of Scientology it was
officially considered a church in the
eyes of the government and therefore was
a tax-exempt organization Hubbard was
making money as people joins the church
bought materials and spends money to
move through the ranks of Scientology
one session with a Scientology auditor
could cost a person $300 and of course
you could not just have one session as
you kept working your way up getting
closer to being clear you'd have to
spend more money to work with auditors
and to achieve more within the church
people were spending a lot of money to
be a member of Scientology and to
achieve what Hubbard had promised them
was possible but just because
Scientology was growing and was flush
with cash doesn't mean it was without
its problems governments targeted the
organization worried about the
consequences of Scientology on the
health of its members and there was also
this growing reputation for intimidation
among Scientologists the Australian
government even went so far as to say
that Scientology was a serious threat to
the community
medically morally and socially and its
adherents sadly deluded and often
mentally ill the United States
government was also concerned in fact
they had been watching Hubbard for years
some reports even say that the FBI had
interviewed him as early as 1951 and was
not happy with his mental state in 1963
the Washington DC Scientology Church was
raided the feds discovered just how much
Hubbard was making off the church he was
taking millions out of the coffers of
this organization and paying no taxes to
the governments it was this the cause
Scientology to lose its tax-exempt
status
Hubbard wasn't willing to let this
treatment by the US government stand
though he created a new office within
Scientology to deal with negative
publicity the Scientologists in charge
of this office took aim aggressively
liberally accusing Scientology's
detractors of libel and slander Hubbard
wanted to bring down his attackers and
was willing to do whatever it took to do
so lurid blood sex crime actual evidence
is what he wanted his publicity office
to find on those who were attacking
Scientology's reputation
even with an aggressive publicity
approach a Scientology didn't get their
tax-exempt status back for another 30
years as the church came under attack
from governments Hubbard saw a solution
on the open seas where governments
couldn't get him it was this that caused
him to dream up another organization
this one known as Sea Org the Sea Org
was basically Scientology on the ocean
with its members living aboard three
ships that Hubbard had purchased there
was a major cash flow to be welcomed
into the Sea Org you had to sign a
contract saying that you would be loyal
to Scientology for 1 billion yes even
though the group was based aboard ships
they still faced resistance from
governance the Greek government asked
them to leave Corfu after a year and
Morocco was no more welcoming to them
being part of the Sea Org and sailing
around the world was not akin to being
on a cruise ship though instead there
was little food long hours for those
tending to the ship and dirty clothes
and linens were the North Hubbard
himself only lasted on the open sea for
a few years it taken breaks on land in
the early 1970s but in 1975 he returned
to life on land for good upon his return
he settled in California and after two
decades in the spotlight l ron Hubbard
began to fade away from his charismatic
leadership role in the church the years
on the ocean had not a raised
Scientology's problems with the
government's Hubbard in his organization
were being chased by French and US
authorities and even managed to get
themselves embroiled in Moroccan
political issues while there Sea Org
ships were docked at Hubbard's solution
to these problems wants to keep himself
hidden the church kept fighting with
Hubbard pulling the strings and
directing operations that went to
elaborate lengths to infiltrate the
federal government's and disrupt
investigations one operation called Snow
White involved everything from breaking
into IRS officers to bugging the federal
government to even infiltrating
government staff with Scientology plants
you could report back to the church a
former Scientologists said that Hubbard
always said never defend always attack
this was gospel and that's pretty much
what the church did and it landed 11
people in jail including Hubbard's wife
as all of this was going on Hubbard was
still hiding out at home he suffered
from a number of health problems
throughout the 1970s and nine
in eighties a heart attack pulmonary
embolism injuries sustained in a
motorcycle accident and more he was
obese and he smoked constantly the man
simply wasn't healthy he moved around
trying to stay out of the public eye and
away from potential government action
against him he had a team of teenagers
who took care of him washing his clothes
and holding out ashtrays for his
ever-present cigarettes by 1986 his
health issues had mounted to a point
where they couldn't be overcome at the
age of 74 l ron Hubbard passed away
after suffering a stroke when he died he
hadn't made a public appearance in six
years the New York Times said mystery
surrounds his death just as a cloaked
the final years of his life he was
cremated and his ashes were scattered at
sea by Scientologists seven years after
Hubbard's death in 1993 the IRS
reinstated the church's tax-exempt
status the IRS has not given an
explanation about why it was granted
again but the Scientologists could
celebrate their nearly eight billion
dollars in assets were once again safe
from taxation l ron Hubbard's life is
fraught with contradictions between
church teachings and official government
documents and he's certainly a
controversial figure a California judge
ruling on his Scientology lawsuit didn't
hide his feelings about Hubbard at all
the evidence portrays a man who has been
virtually a pathological liar when it
comes to his history backgrounds and
achievements he had egoism greed avarice
lust for power and vindictiveness and
aggressiveness against persons perceived
by him to be disloyal or hostile Hubbard
was a Midwestern boy with an imagination
and an aptitude for language that we
didn't fare well at George Washington
University he was able to use his
charisma and considerable aptitude for
propaganda to build an organization that
remains largely intact today it's
attracted the likes of Tom Cruise and
other Hollywood luminaries to its ranks
and although it takes hits after hit in
the press Scientology marches on and l
ron Hubbard has a legacy that lives on
controversial though it may be so I
really hope you enjoyed that video if
you did please do hit that thumbs up
button below and don't forget to
subscribe for brand new videos every
Monday and Thursday also check out some
of our other videos which are over there
on the right and as always thank you for
watching